[Music]
the stock market is back up after
falling off a cliff
earlier this year you know we've had
these furious rallies investors continue
to put their money into our stock market
you're seeing new record highs on the s
p
and nasdaq major indexes haven't just
recovered from the coronavirus shock
they're on a historic winning streak but
while stocks climbed
millions lost their jobs and fell out of
the labor force
companies say more layoffs could come
this fall
this means that the wealthiest americans
are netting huge returns
while the poorest are losing
opportunities to make money i think the
question on
everyone's mind has been how is the
economy
so bad while the stock market is soaring
higher and higher
to get a sense for the disconnect you
can look at the labor market
we still have 11 million uh people
out of the 22 million who were laid off
from
in the payroll numbers in march and
april still 11 million out there
and that's that's really good progress
we've we've put fully half of those back
to work but that's a long way to go
our economy had come to a standstill
during the pandemic
americans are getting laid off they're
making less money they're spending
less money and all of that hurts our
economy about half of the workers in the
leisure and hospitality industry
lost their jobs this summer casinos
airports and music venues
sat virtually empty that's weighing on
consumer spending
it plummeted in march and still hasn't
reached pre-pandemic levels
experts say that this is unlikely to
change until the virus is contained
that means businesses are making fewer
sales and hiring fewer people
there were 10.7 million fewer us jobs in
september
versus february that will make it more
difficult for the unemployed to find
work
despite a crumbling economy the stock
market has soared
and there are a few forces driving that
rally
most notable were the policies coming
out of america's central bank
we acted forcefully to get our markets
working again and as a result
market conditions have generally
improved in march
the fed made emergency loans available
to banks local governments and other
players in the global economy
that kept investors optimistic about the
future and that
can drive up the markets investors said
the fed stepped in
like they'd never had before their
response was quicker
and more muscular than ever before and
that was a
key driver for the stock market this
spring
the bank started by slashing interest
rates to near zero which made it cheaper
to borrow money
then the bank started to buy debt by
september the fed controlled seven
trillion dollars worth of assets
up from four trillion at the beginning
of the pandemic
over coming months we will continue to
increase our holdings of treasury
securities and agency mortgage-backed
securities
at least at the current pace these asset
purchases are intended to sustain
smooth market functioning and help
foster accommodated financial conditions
the bank's purchasing has sent yields on
traditionally safe government debt
to near all-time lows that's driving
investors towards stocks
treasuries all of a sudden don't look as
attractive because the yield on them
is so low so if you want returns
you might as well go to stocks and
that's kind of the calculus that a lot
of investors have been doing
and it's actually people call it the
puerto quotina effect there is no
alternative to stocks because
yields are just so low where else are
you going to go for returns
this and other actions from the fed
propped up the markets and the money
that flowed from these policies went
into one section of the market in
particular
technology tech stocks lifted entire
market indexes this year
you can see that by comparing the tech
heavy nasdaq and s
p indices to the performance of the dow
jones industrial average
it's easy to think like wow stocks are
doing so well but
what we've seen this year is that it's
really a handful of stocks that are
doing really well and
those are mainly technology companies
apple microsoft amazon
facebook alphabet these big names offer
products that were crucial to live life
and conduct business in the pandemic
and their leaders took note on earnings
calls this summer this was a strong
quarter for us especially
compared to what we expected at the
start we began to see a significant
increase in customer demand beginning in
early march
in an uncertain environment apple saw a
quarter of historic results
investors expect solid earnings from
these companies which will boost demand
for their stock
you really can't overstate how well
these tech companies have done this year
and what a big role that plays in
driving the s p 500 up higher
apple alone recently was worth more than
all of the stocks in the ftse 100 index
or
all of the companies in this russell
2000 index of small stocks
tech stocks are doing so well their
gains are outweighing losses and
financial companies and energy stocks
which haven't been able to rally smaller
businesses are hurting too
bill ackman of pershing square holdings
said that if there were a stock market
index of private small businesses
it would likely be down 50 or more
while investors lock in expectations for
earnings in tech
a flood of action from individual
investors is also changing the markets
you're seeing newbie investors who had
never traded before they were stuck at
home during the pandemic and they
opened up brokerage accounts because
it's never been easier to trade it's
never been easier to open account
digital brokers like robinhood offer
commission free trading which has drawn
more investors into the market
during the first six months of the year
individual investors made up about 20
of market activity that's about a five
percentage point jump from last year
analysts said smaller investors drove up
stocks like nikola and eastman kodak
but they don't impact bigger names like
apple and tesla
brokers are making markets more
accessible but that's not helping the
bottom half of american workers
workers from lower income households
were more likely to lose their jobs in
the pandemic
and many in this group have historically
been shut out of the stock market
most stocks are held by the top 10 of
americans by wealth
according to data from the federal
reserve charts like this
sum up why a booming stock market seems
disconnected from the economic reality
for many americans